now I do want to talk about how we met
please let's talk about first of all
there were rumors that there was this
really hot guy that worked here anyway
so I usually don't go to the bathroom
alone I'm one of those people that I
like to go with several people I
um I like to have a conversation when
I'm going to the bathroom yeah so I
usually will bring people in we'll cross
stream sometimes so I finally saw you in
the bathroom I don't really blame you
for this because I think it's a design
flaw but basically there is a one urinal
and I think three stalls right three
stalls yeah one of them is a handicap
stall and it's a big heavy door
however what people don't realize when
they go in there is that the two stalls
the smaller stalls are hinged the doors
are hinged on the right and they open in
yeah the handicapped door is hinged on
the left and opens out yes you got
confused and you ran directly into the
door and hit your head pretty hard yes
but there's a little bit more
information tell me okay so you were
talking to whoever was in the bathroom
with you yes and I didn't want to be
rude and walk between you guys to get to
the sink and wash my hat okay so I said
I'll go behind and I pushed the door the
wrong way so much so that when I let go
of the door it hits you it hit me in the
face it's pretty bad it [__] hurt
yeah no no it's bad and Jeff was like oh
my God this happened to me too before in
the back of my head I'm like [__] it
never happened I've never [__] never
had before never it hurt it was
traumatic it was traumatic but I imagine
you felt uncomfortable in that moment
too like I felt bad yeah it was really
humiliating yeah you looked stupid yeah
I looked like an [__] yeah can I tell
you something I don't do any other shows
on SiriusXM so what made you do this
okay you want to be honest yeah okay so
I was pulling in the parking structure
and I was like [__] it's early we gotta
go you know it's like stress I have to
do my radio show after this and then I
have to film today and I'm like you know
I just hold Shane Jeff's assistant who's
sitting in the studio right now yeah uh
I said you know the only reason I'm
doing the show right and Shane's like
yeah I'm like because rasan's hot
that's it
foreign